as riot spread throughout america's
major cities democrats try to pin the
blame on trump
sports figures come under fire for
standing up for the american flag and
netflix
releases a bizarre video pushing doctors
to abandon medicine for feelings i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben and make the magic happen okay so
every weekend
i basically say don't burn the place
down and then you went and you burned
the place down and
when i say you burned the place down i
don't mean people who listen to the show
i mean all the other jerks
i'm talking about folks in seattle
burning the place down and portland
burning the place down and oakland
burning the place down and austin
burning the place down and louisville
burning the place
just all sorts of fun happening all over
the country why
well because there's a general mood and
the general mood is the american system
sucks
and liberals are going to let the
leftists get away with this here is the
deal
conservatives are not capable on their
own of stopping the chaos that is now
engulfing the country these are liberal
cities they are run by democrats and
until democrats decide that they are
done with this
this is not going to end if they decide
they are going to simply allow the woke
left to eat their cities alive
there's not much the right can do about
that president trump can set in some
federal forces to defend federal
property but
the federal government is not given the
job generally speaking of
re-establishing
generalized law and order in america's
major cities
the tenor of american federalism
suggests that local localities and
states are responsible for ensuring
that people abide by the law in
localities and states it's not the job
of the federal government
to make sure that basic criminal law is
followed that is the job of the states
if states and localities refuse to do it
the predictable result
that everybo will be that everybody who
has any shred of money will get out
that everybody who is living in these
cities is not going to stick around and
provide the tax base
to quote unquote fix the problems of
inequality they're just going to leave
and then presumably they will be blamed
by the new york times for not sticking
around you saw this a little bit with
joe rogan
over the weekend so my favorite tweet of
the weekend so joe rogan is moving
from los angeles to texas which i
already knew since joe and i are very
friendly
and the and the media were angry at him
because he said the reasons that he were
moving included bad
local governance and the upkeep of the
area where he lives which by the way is
true like la has turned into a trashy
and people like no the real reason he's
moving is because he just signed a 100
million
deal with spotify and because the state
tax rates in california are 13.3 percent
it's like okay so he's bad for escaping
the tax rates i've been told by the left
that they can raise the tax rates know
as high as they want and no one will
ever react to those tax rates
so are you going to blame him for
reacting to the tax rates or are you
going to hold with the idea
that the tax rates have no impact on
people leaving in other words democrats
keep making giant cities unlivable and
then people leave they're like why are
you leaving
where are you going why why don't you
stick around i mean we just want to
steal more of your money and use it for
random crap like porta-potties under the
overpasses
which is what we got here in california
brand new construction happening here in
los angeles
every underpass for a freeway shall have
a porta potty it is it is grand and
glorious construction when we talk about
green new jobs it's really brown new
jobs here
in the city of los angeles but bottom
line is this
whether it's cancel culture whether it's
the destruction of america's major
cities
so long as mainstream liberals go along
with the woke left
so long as that is the coalition so long
as mainstream liberals
see a greater danger to the country in
mainstream conservatives
than they do in the woke left then the
alliance of the work left and the
liberals actually is a majority in the
country
right there's a significant minority in
the country that is conservative
but these sort of mainstream liberal
kind of good-hearted folks who don't pay
too much attention to politics so long
as they keep caving to the woke left
the woke left will have the whip hand in
american politics and that's what we are
watching
right now according to the new york
times from los angeles to new york
protesters marched in a show of
solidarity with demonstrations in
portland oregon
in seattle they smashed windows and set
fires a shooting at a protest in austin
texas
left one man dead so things are going
really great one thing you may have
noticed
i just read you about a series of cities
one thing they have in common let's see
la new york portland oregon seattle
austin what do all these places have in
common
it's not demographics portland's a very
white city los angeles is a very
hispanic city
new york is a fairly racially diverse
city
austin is largely white it has nothing
to do with color what do these places
have in common
they are all places where the left runs
the place all of them
they're not trying this crap in the
middle of slate in texas
and they ain't trying this crap in the
middle of
idaho right red areas are not seeing
this and the reason red areas are not
seeing this is because the woke left
understands
that the people that they can capture
the institutions they can capture are
all run by mainstream liberals
according to the new york times weeks of
violent clashes between federal agents
and protesters in portland oregon
galvanized thousands of people to march
through the streets of american cities
on saturday
injecting new life into protests that
had largely waned in recent weeks
one of the most intense protests was in
seattle where a day of demonstrations
focused on police violence
left a trail of broken windows and
people flushing pepper spray from their
eyes
at least 45 protesters had been arrested
as of early evening both protesters and
police officers
suffered injuries yes the difference is
that the protesters
are generally rioting and looting and
the police officer generally attempting
to enforce the law love that moral
equivalence there
between quote unquote protesters notice
how the media are deliberately
anti-specific here right they're not
saying what these quote unquote
protesters were doing
generally the protesters are not being
arrested for protesting
in fact not generally it's not a crime
to protest in the united states
they're being arrested for violating the
law
and carrying signs such as feds go home
and shouting chance of no justice no
peace
some among the crowd about 5 000
protesters stopped at a youth detention
center
and lit several construction trailers
there on fire in seattle
some smashed windows of nearby
businesses ignited a fire in a coffee
shop
blew an eight-inch hole through the wall
of the seattle police department's east
precinct building
according to the police at this point we
declared the event to be a riot and
several orders to disperse were given
said seattle police chief carmen best
the police responded by firing flash
grenades showering protesters with
pepper spray
abruptly rushing into crowds knocking
people to the ground
after a flash grenade left one woman
with bloody injuries police officers
shoved people who had stopped to help
her
because they were going to arrest her
presumably also because the people who'd
stopped to help her might not have been
helping her
in austin texas the police said one man
was shot and killed just before 10 pm
during a protest in the city's downtown
in a live video from the scene
protesters are seen marching through the
intersection when a car blares its horn
several seconds later five shots ring
out followed shortly by several more
loud bangs
the man who was killed may have
approached a vehicle with a rifle
before he was shot and killed officer
katrina ratcliffe said
miss ratcliffe said the person who shot
and killed the man had fired from inside
the vehicle
that person was detained and is
cooperating with officer she said no one
else was injured
mayor steve adler of austin said all i
know is someone dying while protesting
is horrible he wasn't protesting when
you approach somebody on a public
highway
carrying a rifle and pointing it at them
which is apparently what happened here
that's called self-defense now again if
you don't believe me that is
very very similar to the case of
ahmedabary where i've said that the
people are being justly tried on murder
charges
okay you do not have the right to hold
someone up at gunpoint on a public
thoroughfare
and for idiots we're trying to compare
that to the couple in missouri who are
standing on their own property
holding guns to defend their own
property not the same thing one is on
their property
one is if they went in the middle of the
street and pointed a gun at somebody in
a car
not the same thing you idiots our city
is shaking like so many in our community
i'm heartbroken and stunned said mayor c
vadler of austin we'll get to what's
happening in la in just one second
and then we'll get to why liberals are
allowing this to happen why these are
cities they run
why are they allowing this to happen
because there is a method to the madness
we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about that
wireless bill how you doing on that
wireless bill you know
great i didn't think so you're spending
too much on your wireless why are you
spending so much on your wireless well
probably you think to yourself
they said unlimited data and then you
look and you haven't been using anything
close to unlimited data you've been
using like
not all that much data you're just using
it a lot for talk and text this is why
you need
pure talk usa who's your wireless
provider att verizon t-mobile what if i
told you pure talk usa
uses the exact same network as one of
those carriers same towers same exact
coverage
but literally cost you half how do they
make it so affordable well no retail
stores no low
so low overhead you're not funding
billion dollar ad campaigns you're only
paying for the data you need
no contract no excessive fees you'll
enjoy unlimited talk text and two gigs
of data
all for just 20 bucks a month the
average person is saving 400 bucks a
year on their wireless bill by using
pure talk
usa so grab that mobile phone dial pound
250 and say ben
shapiro when you do you get 250 bucks
off any iphone
including the brand new iphone se again
that is pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro you get 250
bucks off any iphone including that
brand new iphone sc
pound two five zero and say keyword ben
shapiro
pound 250 say my name and get that
magical magical discount and save money
on your wireless at the same time so
seems like a great deal
okay according to the new york times in
l.a protesters clashed with officers in
front of the federal courthouse downtown
videos showed people smashing windows
lobbing water bottles at officers after
protesters
said police fired projectiles at them
okay i have a feeling that this went the
other way around
i don't think the police are willy-nilly
firing projectiles of people because
they will lose their jobs and or be sued
and or go to jail for that
my guess is that protesters are lobbing
things to the cops the federal
courthouse in portland
has been the scene of nightly chaotic
demonstrations for weeks which continued
again
into sunday morning as thousands
participated in marches around the city
the 59th consecutive day of protest
there earlier a group of nurses and
scrubs
enjoyed an organized group of mothers
and helmets and fathers and hard hats
all assembled against the fence of a
federal courthouse where federal agents
have been assembled
also they decided to get together the
village people that's exciting stuff
they got the guys in the heart the hard
hats they got the mothers they need a
native american guy
they got the nurses and scrubs by the
way quick rule about nurses and scrubs
okay so
as some of you may know i have a wife
who is a doctor you don't wear scrubs
outside the hospital
not a thing you do the reason is because
if you are wearing scrubs as a costume
generally that's stupid and if you're
wearing scrubs directly from the
hospital you're supposed to take them
off because they're covered in germs
anyway
shortly after 1 am the portland police
said the protest had become a riot and
ordered the crowd to leave
federal agents fired tear gas and left
the courthouse to drive protesters from
the streets
continuing to stretch the bounds of
their authority that's not stretching
the bounds of their authority
they have very very clear authority
under 40
u.s code it's 15 19. okay the the
that authority is extraordinarily clear
it says they can defend federal property
and arrest people in the course
of committing crimes not just on the
federal property but around that area
anywhere in that area
portland is leading said chantal
hershberger an organizer with refused
fascism because nothing says refusing
fascism
quite like storming law enforcement
agencies and trying to establish martial
law at the center of nature's major
cities
chantel hershberger part of the los
angeles activists protesting the
presence of federal agents in portland
makes perfect sense by the way
is that there are federal agents in
portland so you go over to the federal
courthouse
in la and go to downtown and you just
shatter some windows there
that makes perfect sense they're showing
what it looks like to stay in the
streets despite police oppression
despite federal forces being sent in
this kind of energy is actually what's
needed
is it is that is that really really is
that what's needed
bipasha mukherjee 52 of kirkland
washington
said she's been protesting on the
streets since may this is what happens
when nobody has a job
said it was worrisome to her to see such
aggressive tactics by the police
this is not the country i immigrated to
said miss mukherjee who arrived from
india more than 30 years ago it feels
like we are rapidly becoming a fascist
state
and a police state really do fascist
police states just let people
willy-nilly burn down courthouses for 59
straight days in portland
is that a thing fascist police states do
because like
my knowledge of fascism suggests that
the cops immediately come in in fascist
states and arrest everyone including the
law-abiding protesters
which is literally the one thing that is
not happening
this is all insane it's a very hard
slide in an extremely violent direction
said michoud
savage of seattle he said the protests
were aimed at both local authorities and
the deployment of federal officers who
waged a crackdown against the
long-running protest in portland
so weird because um i remember when they
set up chas chop
in the middle of seattle before the feds
came in so i feel like the timeline is
not accurate that we are being told
right now
carmen best the seattle police chief a
woman of color who by the way the media
will never note that
said a number of demonstrators use
violence some were tossing concrete
blocks from a rooftop to the street
below
the coffee shop set of fire had occupied
apartments above it that had to be
evacuated
she said we support everyone's first
amendment right for free speech and to
gather and assemble in such a way what
we saw today
was not peaceful it was not a peaceful
demonstration at all criminal acts were
occurring throughout the city
many people were at risk by the way i'm
really enjoying the sight of these giant
crowds protesting
and demonstrating and rioting and
looting that's really exciting stuff in
the middle of a damned pandemic
and the media going well you know
they're standing i'm now like 10
paragraphs
into this new york times story they've
not mentioned the pandemic ones
anti-lactam protests violating pandemic
policies
first sentence churches violating
pandemic policies
first sentence giant enormous protest of
people throwing concrete blocks from
roofs
to the street below no mention of the
fact there's a pandemic none
the largest story on planet earth in the
last probably
maybe since world war ii and people are
out in the streets violating protocol
and not a word from the media not one
word they're protesting for the right
things guys
immunity is conferred by looting and
rioting as long as you're doing so for
the right purposes and the right
purposes apparently are not restricted
to george floyd if you're burning a
federal courthouse for george floyd or
you're burning down a starbucks for
george floyd let me suggest
george floyd was not in favor of burning
down starbucks and if he was that's a
bad thing
this is wild nonsense other
demonstrations took place on saturday in
new york omaha and oakland among other
cities in omaha
kmtv tv reported demonstrators turned
out in solidarity with the portland
protests and also in response to the
death of james scurlock a black man
killed by a white bar owner in may
in that case he was being attacked by
the way that's what actually happened we
discussed the case at the time
in richmond virginia riot police fired
chemical agents at protesters who
marched through the city and gathered
around the richmond police department
the police
said some protesters had set fire to a
city-owned dump truck outside the
station
in aurora colorado a hectic scene played
out as people marched along an
interstate highway
during that protest someone drove a car
into demonstrators according to aurora
police
although it was unclear if the car
struck any protesters okay by the way
quick note
if you gather on a freeway and someone
is driving and you surround their car
they have no obligation
to stop their car and let you savage
them that is not a thing
okay you are violating the law when you
when you crowd so when you mob a car
like i i'm bewildered by this attitude
that as a driver my job is to make sure
that you can surround me rock my car
back and forth and maybe attack me in my
car i don't know what you're going to do
i don't know what you're going to do i
don't know if they're kids in the car
like this is insane
this is totally crazy the police said a
protester had also decided to fire off a
weapon which struck at least one other
person
that person was taken to a hospital was
in stable condition
seattle and portland have seen extended
demonstrations the
the situation in portland continues to
be violent people are firing mortars
apparently
so it's good times in portland now the
video from these places makes
absolutely clear what exactly is going
on and we're going to get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about an issue that can
easily be resolved but it's kind of
embarrassing to talk about i'm talking
about erectile dysfunction of course
with roman
it's easy to talk about it with a
medical professional who can prescribe a
real medication it is simple
safe totally discreet with roman you get
a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home a healthcare
professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate roman will ship it to you
with free two-day shipping
the whole process is straightforward
simple discreet getting started is
really easy just go to getroman.com
ben complete an online visit erectile
dysfunction used to be tough to tackle
now there is roman complete that online
visit today connect with a healthcare
professional get it taken care of go to
getroman.com
ben today if approved you get 15 bucks
off your first order of ed treatment
that's it get roman.com getroman.com
ben go check them out right now again if
you're dealing with a medical problem
something people do they tend to wish it
away except this stuff ain't going to
get wished away you just need to get it
solved if it's ed it's really affecting
your life go get it solved right now by
going to getroman.com
ben if approved you get 15 bucks off
your first order of
ed treatment getroman.comroman.com
men okay so the video from these places
makes perfectly clear exactly what is
going on
in seattle they burn to starbucks one of
the great ironic tweets of the day
was by a person who was living above
that starbucks and had tweeted
that the police are being fascist and
brutal and then was like why are they
burning the starbucks this is terrible
man they really must hate that starbucks
as i've said before the shooting of the
oil cans in the jerk with steve martin
they really hate these oil cans
or alternatively starbucks has nothing
to do with anything and is a major
employer in the area and they just
ransacked the place and looted it
and of course they've got the a-cab
graffiti up there a-cab
is all cops are bleep so that's that's
good that's good times
because the cops run starbucks did you
know starbucks by the way a company
so woke that they refused to expel
people who literally sit there
and use their facilities and won't buy
anything and give
sensitivity training if one of their own
woke brand managers
says the person has to leave that's how
woke starbucks is
they're getting ripped up there is the
starbucks being destroyed
meanwhile the seattle pd put out a
notice
okay this is from carmen best according
to reagan battalion
put out july 24th quote dear business
owner and or resident
please know the seattle police
department is committed to addressing a
life safety incidents and calls for
service
and responding to ongoing demonstrations
and unrest in the city please
also know that the city council
ordinance 119505
crowd control tool goes into effect this
weekend sunday july 26th
this ordinance bans seattle police
officers the use of less lethal tools
including pepper spray that is commonly
used to disperse crowds that have turned
violent
simply put the legislation gives
officers no ability
to safely intercede to preserve property
in the midst of a large violent crowd
it is important to bring to your
attention that yesterday i sent the city
council a letter
ensuring them that as chief of police i
have done my due diligence of informing
them numerous times of the foreseeable
impact of this ordinance on upcoming
events
the letter is attached for your
reference for these reasons seattle
police will have an adjusted
deployment in response to any
demonstrations these will this weekend
as i will never ask our officers to risk
their personal safety to protect
property without the tools to do so
in a safe way that's insane
so the seattle pd is already announcing
that if you mob a place they're not
showing up because they don't have
pepper spray because the city council
ban the pepper spray
they're announcing preemptive surrender
preemptive surrender seattle pd is
saying you're on your own guys
sorry not much we can do also the pd
has announced in seattle that they've
been arresting people who are firing
mortars
mortars police have made at least three
arrests in seattle pd over the weekend
and continue to work to disperse large
crowd on capitol hill earlier incident
was determined to be a life safety issue
violation
declared a riot individuals continued to
throw explosives and fire mortars at
police
at least two officers have been injured
so that's what's happening in seattle
where by the way this thing didn't start
right seattle here we now have this
running cycle right this started with
chop chas in seattle then portland was
like you know what's great chop chaz
let's do that here
then the feds came in and then seattle's
like that's bad the feds went to
portland let's do it again
solid solid stuff happening all across
the country meanwhile
in portland chad wolf the head of the
dhs the acting secretary of dhs who's on
the show last week he announced
that several federal officers may have
been blinded they may have lost their
vision
as a result of these bastards in the
streets firing lasers into the eyes of
federal law enforcement
here's chad wolfe explaining we have
two to three different officers uh we
are waiting on final results to see
how much of their eyesight will
permanently be lost
because of the activity of these
criminals as you indicated they are
shining lasers
high powerful lasers in the officer's
eyes as they emerge from the courthouse
so we're taking steps we've taken steps
to address that
uh and we'll continue to protect our
officers at all costs
and again all i need is the city of
portland to step
up and do their job this is insane
insane federal police officers
federal law enforcement are being
blinded on the job
and the media are like trump trump's so
bad
trump's so bad by the way portland's
basically shut down so thanks to the
pandemic
business was already pretty slow now
because they're basically taking over
city blocks antifa and tossing trash
everywhere they're trusting trash at
police officers trying to draw a
responsibility response
now businesses are not even operating in
portland according to the
oregonian office buildings remain empty
because of the pandemic tourists have
yet to return
taking away a large customer base for
many downtown businesses
more tents have appeared along the
sidewalks in your downtown as the city
has limited cleanups of homeless camps
due to the pandemic those factors have
limited foot traffic in downtown
trimet says trips downtown are down more
than 75 this summer compared to last
year
parking meter transactions are down a
similar amount hotel occupancy
in the central state is the worst in the
state down 73 percent
eric murphy controller of mercantile a
family-owned downtown clothing store
that's been in business for 45 years
reopened his shop in may when oregon
governor kate brown eased coronavirus
restrictions for many businesses
mercantile's reopening was short-lived
thousands of demonstrators took to the
streets
on the night of may 30th to protest
police brutality
but the night of a people ended with
break-ins and looting in downtown
murfree watched on his live security
footage feet as looters trashed his
stores and police officers failed to
intervene
he said officers later came to take a
statement and collect security footage
but haven't been in touch since
other businesses that were hit that
night told similar stories
murphy like other downtown business
owners said he's a strong supporter
of blm but he is not sympathetic to
those that have used the movement as a
cover for looting and violence
he said he said he hopes his store can
reopen in august but he needs assurances
his business can be protected
the most important pressing thing on my
mind is that city leadership is going to
do
to restore peace and order by the way i
i do love the irony of people saying i'm
the big blm
supporter also they're calling for
defund the police also i want the police
to protect me
it's one thing to say that you are
against police brutality like all
sentient humans
it is another thing to say that you are
a big supporter of black lives matter
whose chief agenda item is defunding the
police and having them not protect
law-abiding citizens we're going to get
to
more places that have turned into
centers of chaos across the country
in just one second including in in
portland there's a story from ap that
demonstrates just how wild things are
getting and
democrats in denial like open denial and
or threatening that this stuff isn't
gonna end unless donald trump leaves
office
which is saying the quiet part out loud
which is basically threatening law
abiding american citizens
we are going to burn the major cities
until we get what we want
which is effectively a form of terrorism
okay
terrorism is the use of violence to
enact a political end
right the use of illegal violence in
order to enact a political end is
basically the textbook definition of
terrorism if you are burning down
cities and saying we're going to do this
until you elect our candidate
hard not to see that as a form of
terrorism okay we're going to get to
more of this in
just one second first when running a
business hr issues can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
hr managers salaries aren't cheap
they're an average of seventy thousand
bucks a year
bambi can solve all this for you bambi's
bamb ee
was created specifically for small
business you get a dedicated hr manager
craft hr policy and maintain your
compliance all for just 99 bucks a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager available by
phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
it's month to month there are no hidden
fees you can cancel anytime because when
you start a business it's because you
want to provide
goods and services to consumers because
you want to do something creative and
awesome you want to hire people you know
it's one thing
you don't want to do spend all your time
dealing with hr issues they're such
a nightmare go to bambi.com right now
schedule your free hr audit that's bam
to the be dot com
slash bureau bam to the be.com shapiro
and schedule your free hr audit
right now and make sure that you are
covered on the hr front will make your
life better it'll make your business
better you can't afford any
hr problems right now bambi.com
for that free hr audit okay so over in
portland
according to the associated press as
night fell
music stopped and the march to the
federal courthouse began two blocks west
one block south the several dozen
federal law enforcement agents guarding
the mark hatfield federal courthouse
could see the protesters coming
under orders to protect the courthouse
federal property that has been
increasingly targeted as the city's
protests against racial injustice march
on
the agents were accustomed to the drill
tonight the crowd was huge estimated at
000 people the largest they had seen
the top commander with the u.s marshal
service peered out a window facing the
willamette river and watched the sea of
humanity sweep toward him it was going
to be another long night
the courthouse looked like a feudal
castle under siege the outside was
boarded up with thick plywood
narrow slits at the top of the plywood
accessed by a mechanized scaffolding
gave the agents inside a view of the
crowd and an opening through which to
fire pepper balls
the terrace outside the front door was
littered with garbage the steps leading
to the courthouse splattered with paint
a mixture of anti-police and blm
graffiti covered the building's outer
walls and columns to a height of about
10 feet
tear gas still hung in the air coated
the floor with a slime that had been
hurtly mopped up by the custodians
earlier that day
in the no man's land outside stood the
fence a thick black iron installation
erected six days before a dividing line
between protesters and protector a stark
separation
between two radically different world
views to the protesters the man inside
the men inside the baton town courthouse
are our best thoughtless political
minions
at worst murderous henchmen for
protecting a courthouse
for protecting a courthouse why because
again there's a deeper ideology at work
it's something i discuss in my new book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps
i say in the book there will be
tolerance of violence it will happen
from the left
because people have decided the system
is rotten to the core and that means
that all the elements of the system
including courthouses have to go to the
agents inside the demonstrations that
pack
the downtown each night are violent to
anarchists well yes
yes according to one deputy u.s marshal
he said i can't walk outside without
being in fear of my life i'm worried for
my life every time i walk outside
the building journalists from the ap
were both outside with the protesters
and
inside and what they report from the
inside is pretty damned frightening
at 10 15 p.m in portland the protesters
made their first foray into conflict a
man tried to climb the fence was quickly
arrested
30 minutes later the fence rocked and
leaned sharply as dozens of protesters
pressed their weight against it
some of them throwing their bodies
against it at a running start
the fence undulated like a wave and
tilted dangerously before springing back
behind the front lines drummers that had
whipped demonstrations up at the
fountain regrouped and led the crowd
in dancing and chanting
four small pods of three to four
protesters dressed in black circulated
in the crowd
stopping every few minutes to point
green laser beams in the eyes of agents
posted as lookouts
on porticos in the courthouse's upper
stories the agents above were
silhouetted against the dark sky as
dozens of green laser dots and a large
spotlight played on courthouse walls
projected from the back of the crowd by
the way those laser beams are designed
to blind agents
inside the courthouse it was dark pitch
black except for one narrow ceiling bulb
that cast a cone of light over the
stairs
without lights the agents hope they
would be better protected from people in
the crowd who are firing
metal ball bearings through the windows
with slingshots
thick ribbons of green light from
blinding lasers crisscrossed the
courthouse lobby this is
mad max kind of stuff forcing the agents
who are resting in between deployments
to the fence to duck and weave to
protect their eyes
agents on scaffolding fired pepper balls
through the window slits at the crowd
while others sat quietly on marble
benches in the lobby alone or in small
groups and waited for their turn
at the fence every few minutes the huge
boom from commercial grade fireworks
tossed over the fence caused the walls
to rattle the crowd outside cheered as
explosions of red white and green
flashed against a thick curtain of
yellowish tear gas and by the way
they've been throwing cans and rocks at
the officers
good stuff good stuff now what exactly
are people doing about this
the democrats are doing nothing
literally nothing the police officers do
not exist in this region
i talked to ami horowitz who was in
portland a couple of days ago
my friend ami the the documentarian
he said the cops were nowhere to be
found mayor ted wheeler has pulled the
cops
and meanwhile over in oakland hundreds
of protesters have taken the streets of
downtown oakland saturday night
some vandalized the police station broke
windows spray painted shot fireworks
pointed lasers at officers and
helicopters according to officials
police said demonstrators in the area of
17th and lakeside are breaking windows
enchanting racial slurs as residents
that's not something that'll be widely
reported i would imagine they're
chancing racial slurs you know to stand
up for tolerance and diversity
and how america is racist meanwhile in
austin a man was shot dead
he was shot dead because apparently
according to local according to local
police
he approached a car on the on the
freeway basically
which was surrounded and pointed the gun
at the person in the car who happened to
be armed
according to the new york times garrett
foster was carrying an ak-47 rifle as he
joined a blm
demonstration blocks from the state
capitol in austin
foster wearing a black bandana and a
baseball cap bumped into an independent
journalist march on saturday he spoke
matter-of-factly about the weapon
he said they don't let us march in the
streets anymore so i gotta practice some
of our rights he said if i use it
against cops i'm dead
later that night he was fatally shot but
not by the cops the authority said he
was killed by a motorist
who had a confrontation with with
protesters the police and witnesses said
the man in the car turned it
aggressively toward the marchers and
foster then approached it
the driver opened fire shooting foster
three times he was rushed to a hospital
and was later pronounced dead okay that
is one description of the incident
another local description of the
incident
says the opposite austin's police chief
told the reporters as the motorist
turned
a crowd of protesters surrounded the
vehicle some struck the car
the driver then opened fired from inside
the car as foster approached
because he was carrying a gun
approaching the car minutes after the
shooting the driver called 9-1-1
said he'd been involved in a shooting
and driven away from the scene the
caller said he'd shot someone who had
approached the driver's window and
pointed a rifle
at him his account is that foster
pointed the weapon directly at him and
he fired his handgun
at foster both the driver and the person
who fired and the other person fired a
weapon were detained
and interviewed by detectives
so the way the media are going to cover
this is that it's the murder of a
protester when in fact it turns out
there's a disputed circumstance and it
turns out that
according to witnesses and the person in
the car the car was surrounded by people
which by the way
if you're around as i've said before if
you are surrounded
by a bunch of people and you keep
driving
that is not your fault what are you
supposed to do just sit there as people
try to
break you i mean like i don't understand
i don't understand the logic here
in a story that is not going to be
mentioned by the media by the way
there is a a blue lives matter protester
who is run down deliberately apparently
by a man in a maroon suv this is in
eaton colorado
local police said on facebook they
responded about 3 30 pm to a report of a
man in a maroon suv attempting to drive
through or over a crowd of pedestrians
those pedestrians were holding a blue
lives matter demonstration amazing one
of these things will be covered
by the mass media one of these things
will not right one is a disputed
situation in which a protester
who is armed and is now and is
approaching on public property
a a person he's not licensed to protest
presumably
stopping cars in the middle of the road
right and allegedly pointing a gun at
the car before being shot that will be
covered widely in the media
a man running down blue lives matter
protesters that will not receive
national media coverage in any real way
again the cause matters here right the
cause matters here if if the narrative
does not support what is being driven by
the media namely that the protesters are
peaceful and wonderful
and everybody else is super bad then
they just will ignore the story for the
most part
the good news is that we do have some
peaceful protest by the way there was
yoga against racism in dc
so that was exciting i thought it was
really great i mean like there it is
you see how how we're solving racism one
tree pose at a time one downward dog at
a time
solving racism by white woke ladies
in lululemon pants very exciting stuff
by the way we are we are very serious in
this country this is very serious stuff
you know we're serious when
we're having giant dance parties in the
middle of pandemic and yoga classes
to protest in favor of black lives
matter very solid stuff so what is the
democratic agenda here
why exactly is this not being shut down
this is all happening universally in
democratic cities
why we'll get to that in just one second
first
let's talk about the fact that hiring
can be difficult but if you're a company
that's currently trying to hire
you face new difficulties from safely
reopening your doors to finding the
right person for a specialized role
housing wire could relate they needed to
hire an ambitious reporter to cover news
on the us mortgage and housing markets
so they turned a zip recruiter
zip recruiter smart matching technology
finds people with the right experience
for your job in fact four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter got
a quality candidate within the very
first day that's how housing wire
found alexandra roja alexandra didn't
think she could get a reporter job in
the middle
of a pandemic but in fact she could she
created a profile on zip recruiter
zipper crew matched her to the housing
wire job and she got her dream career
started
zipper crew helped alexandra find the
right job they helped housing wire find
the right person
for that role we use zip recruiter here
at daily wire so let's say that we had a
producer who made the very poor decision
katie to decide to go into another
profession like you know helping
children or something i mean come on
come on well we would need to replace
somebody presumably
and if we needed to replace somebody we
would probably look to zip recruiters
see how zip recorder can help you hire
try it now for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
dailywire and improve
your business and find wonderful people
like katie to replace wonderful people
like katie try it now for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire go check
them out
right now okay gang if you haven't heard
by now my new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps is
officially on sale
we've been seeing incredible enthusiasm
from you folks we are excited about the
release we did a live signing last
tuesday
we almost sold out so i'm signing copies
my book today
and tomorrow before i get a carpal
tunnel that is the end that is the end
i've signed literally tens of thousands
of copies okay my signature
has been reduced to a mere scroll there
will be no left
in a few days so go get your copy of a
signed copy of how to destroy america in
three easy steps right now dailywire.com
ben as i've been talking about the book
covers the two fundamentally different
visions of america now on the table the
unionist vision
and the disintegrationist vision the
union's vision says we should stay
together as a country
and we have a lot in common like the
philosophy of the declaration of
independence and the history of the
united states
and a culture that actually cares about
abiding by the law
and inculcating virtue and then you have
the disintegrationists who want to
destroy all this stuff
and that's everybody from the 1619
project to the rioters who are
now trying to destroy american cities go
check out how to destroy america in
three easy steps it's not just a
description of the situation or a
prophecy
although it seems really prophetic right
now it also happens to be
a an antidote to what is happening right
now so buy one for yourself and buy one
for somebody
who is a liberal right not somebody on
the local office by somebody who for a
liberal because i promise you they'll
end up agreeing with most of the book
what we need right now is a little unity
against the woke left that is destroying
the country one riot at a time go get
your copy before
it sells out right now get your signed
copy before it sells out right now at
dailywire.com
ben also this has been an insane year
remember that
time when donald trump was impeached by
the house that happened this year
one million years ago and leftist media
they just continue to lie
lie and lie and lie and lie and we'll
get to their coronavirus lies a little
bit later on in the program
when you can't get the real story you
have to go outside the narrative driven
by the media and get the facts so
if you're a political junkie set on
getting both sides of the story and all
the good information get a reader's pass
today from dailywire.com
you'll get access to exclusive op-eds
from us your podcast hosts as well as
guest writers and in-depth analysis from
our daily wire reporters
on top of our regular breaking news you
can go check out articles i've been
writing about coronavirus myths and
the breakdown in civil society today the
membership tier is already a bargain at
three bucks a month if you join today
you get your first month for 99 cents
under a dollar
you also get access to our mobile app
receive push notifications for breaking
news and special content
as well as joining the community of
daily ware members who are actively
commenting and discussing our content
with each other so that's mobile ad free
access to all the daily wire news
exclusive op-eds
of our podcasts on our mobile app all
for the low price of one dollar best of
all
your dollars are getting you the news
you need without the left to spin so
head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe and join today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
well so why are the democrats not doing
anything about this
why why all the cities are burning
they are very upset with president trump
the answer is pretty obvious at this
point
and that is for a lot of democrats
they're willing to wink and not at this
so long as they think it's a political
tool
they believe that a feeling of cast will
drive trump from office trump's the
president
feelings of chaos do not redown to the
benefit of the sitting president and so
they are perfectly willing
to go along with the chaos they are
rooting for the chaos as i mentioned
last week
nancy pelosi who's very very bad at
nicknames by the way she's decided that
president trump is mr make matters worse
which like don't do the nicknames nancy
here she was
let's just get to the heart of it at the
point of all of this is
this president i have a new name for him
mr
make matters worse he has made matters
worse from the start
delay denial it's a hoax it'll go away
magically it's a miracle
and all the rest and we're in this
situation that you
spelled out some of the numbers very
clearly early okay so
they're trying to claim that trump makes
everything worse right from the violence
in america's major cities to the
pandemic it's all about trump
everything's about trump
this is why you get laurie lightfoot the
mayor of chicago who by the way is
taking federal support we mentioned last
week she could have a deal with the feds
to bring in more resources and then she
took down a columbus statue because
she's a weakling
so lori lightfoot the terrible mayor of
chicago who's presided over mass
violence in her streets for
literally at this point years she says
we can't let anybody play police in our
streets
you're right she won't even let the
police play police in her street she
says the feds can't come in here and
and enforce the law that would be bad
no troops no agents that are coming in
outside of our
knowledge notification and control that
are violating people's constitutional
rights
that's the that's the framework we can't
just allow anyone
to come into chicago play police in our
streets in our neighborhoods when they
don't know the first thing
about our city that's a recipe for
disaster and that's what you're seeing
playing out in portland on a nightly
basis we don't need that here
that is not a value-add and it doesn't
help enhance it's true safety it's the
feds
right so it doesn't matter that the
violence preceded the feds it's the feds
right it's all trump's fault
the yeah i've talked about the theory of
trump of the gaps trump of the gaps is
like god of the gaps so atheists
constantly claim
wrongly that religious people find god
where the science doesn't go so
they'll find an area of science that is
not easily explained they'll say ah
that's where god lives
and so atheists call this god of the
gaps argument it's not a particular
it's not a good argument by atheists and
people who use it on the religious side
are not really doing religion correctly
but that is the argument god of the gaps
for the left it's trump of the gaps
anything bad in america can easily be
attributed to trump and also
trump is the big bang of american
politics nothing existed up until trump
and until trump gets involved in an
issue the issue doesn't exist now you
see this from the media all the time so
there will be a major issue that crops
up trump will comment on it it'll be
like
trump launches assault on x
okay riots have been going on in seattle
they're going on in portland
right this has been happening trump
sends in the feds to protect federal
property as he is obligated to do under
federal law
and trump started it time didn't begin
with trump trump is not the big bang of
american politics this stuff's been
going on for weeks
jenny durkin the awful mayor of seattle
she says the fabric of america is being
shredded
not by the people in her streets who've
been taking over city blocks and
wrecking her city for months on end at
this point
it's being shredded because trump sent
in some federal law enforcement to you
know enforce the law
in a way she will not do and again this
is in a city where the seattle police
chief is saying we can't even defend
against mobs because
we've been robbed that ability by the
mayor and the city council
i know how important it is for federal
law enforcement to work
with local law enforcement as a chief
federal law enforcement officer as u.s
attorney
i know that that's an important
relationship i've never seen
anything like this in my career where
federal agents are
sent in not even not with a cooperation
of local law enforcement
but over their objection it's
unprecedented
and it's the wrong way to go the the
fabric of america is being shredded
before our eyes chris
and it worries me greatly the fabric of
america is being not when they have chaz
chop in the middle of her city
and when people are getting shot with
the cops not being there the fabric of
america is shredded by the fact that
president trump
is there right this is the actual
democratic strategy there's a tacit
threat here
ron brownstein is a columnist for the
atlantic
he has a column over the weekend called
trump is determined to split the country
in two
he's trying to rally red america by
portraying blue cities as a threat and
then positioning himself as the human
wall
against them and the basic suggestion
here is that if trump would just leave
it alone or go away like if trump
resigned
everything would be all better that
would fix everything joe scarborough was
doing the same routine over the weekend
he was tweeting out quote much of what
is happening in seattle portland and
other west coast cities is not peaceful
trump's dangerous application of federal
force has elicited
i-l-l-i-c-i-t-e-d okay that's not how
you spell it listed
illicit it would be like i mean i could
make a joke here about um
particular media figures but um he's
looking for eli
c right elicited the response he and bar
were hoping for right it's all about
trump
and if you just got rid of trump then
the violence would go away right this is
the
this is the tacit threat the tacit
threat is unless you get rid of trump
the violence will not go away
unless you give us what we want the
violence will not go away and this has a
long history in democratic politics
unfortunately this has been going on for
literally decades
mayors of local areas basically allowing
violence to creep out of control so they
could then turn to the law abiding
citizens and say you know what we need
to raise our taxes and we need to pay
off these riders they leave you alone
this goes all the way back to the 1960s
there's a a
social scientist named fred siegel one
of the founders of manhattan institute
he wrote a book called the future once
happened here fantastic fantastic book
all about the decline of america's major
cities in the 1960s
prominent politicians he talks about
like attorney general nicholas
katzenbach
warned of riots in 30 or 40 cities if
lbj's favorite legislation providing
funding to inner city communities
was not rammed through congress siegel
wrote as the immediate threat of riots
subsided
liberals would argue that more money for
the cities was essential if not to halt
riots
than to contain the still rising racial
anger which expressed itself in rising
rates of often violent
crime dc mayor marion barry embraced
this logic
you know like the the drug user and
abuser who ended up in jail and then
became mayor again
he said of the violent activities of the
black panthers quote i think that
everything that anybody does is good i'm
serious for instance i know for a fact
that white people get
get scared of the black panthers and
they might look at somebody a little bit
more moderate and say
well let's give them a little money new
york mayor john lindsay
officially a republican but never really
a conservative routinely cave to this
kind of pressure
he said welfare expansion would be a
necessary precondition to stopping riots
he said quote our experience is that
this is one of his aids our experience
is that some good
can come of confrontation politics this
hasn't been relegated to race riots by
the way this has been true
throughout kind of democratic policy
after mlk was murdered in 1968 for
example
the american federation of state county
and municipal employees blackmailed the
city of memphis with the threat of riots
the head of the afscme called an
assistant to then vice president hubert
humphrey
and informed him that violence would
occur if memphis didn't capitulate to
the union demands
he said i don't know what buttons to
press but gd memphis is going to burn
the white house sends an emissary to
memphis and memphis quickly capitulated
to the union and this is the line that
is used by the left on a routine basis
it's been going on for years back in
2016 the riots in milwaukee
and a columnist named german lopez of
vox wrote riots are the culmination of a
serious distrust in the system
and can lead to real substantial change
right now now this is it's fascinating
because there have been some
some studies that you're not allowed to
cite that talk about how riots actually
drive voters away from the causes
rioters back but
in local areas that's not necessarily
true in local areas politicians
either foster the riots or cave to the
riots because they are hopeful that they
can convince everybody
to pay off the rioters and that
everything will go away or they hope
that the writers are
actually pursuing policies they want so
they'll play sort of inside outside game
like ted wheeler is doing in portland
where he's like you know i kind of agree
with the rioters so if they do this
maybe it'll show everybody that the
system's bad and then
i will make some sort of concession and
then everything will go away
well the main line media and left
concession that they're looking for is
for trump to go away the day after joe
biden is elected this all ends
that's a okay that is my prediction
within a month
after joe biden takes office this all
peter's out why
because this because all this is is a
pressure tactic being applied
to law-abiding americans which is
disgusting if you are burning cities
because you're trying to apply pressure
tactics in
any democratic polity
then you are in fact engaging in a form
of political terrorism
and for cities to stand by and cave to
that is not only the height of your
responsibility it's incredibly dangerous
and it makes them complicit in this act
it's horrifying
and that is what you're watching across
the country there is a purpose to the
madness
there's a purpose to the madness people
are fostering the chaos because they
hope that it will end with policy they
like they are hoping to pressure
citizens into capitulating
they are hoping that law abiding
citizens will simply say okay
no moss take my money raise my taxes
get rid of the cops i'll look inside my
own heart of my own white fragility
that's what we've seen in minneapolis
the cops have disappeared the crime
rates are rising
and many white citizens in minneapolis
who feel victimized by the crime right
there's a whole article about this in
the new york times
are saying well you know i guess maybe
we kind of deserve it and maybe we
should do all the things that people
want us to do
none of this is going to alleviate any
of the underlying problems of course
right the fact is that you can tear down
the systems and the great lie is that
when you tear down the systems
everything gets better for everybody
that's a bunch of crap
you turn down the system of law
enforcement the people who pay the most
by every available stat
are poor minorities hey those are the
people who paid the most in new york
they're paying the most in chicago
they're paying the most in la
they're paying the most everywhere those
are the people who feel the brunt
but for the white woke left particularly
and
now they're using blm as sort of an
excuse tearing down the system has
always been the goal so here's the
question are liberals
going to cave to the white woke left are
they going to cave to the
causes of blm which is not white
obviously are they going to cave to the
woke left generally and are they going
to use the woke left as a baton
to club other good little liberals into
line or will there be enough liberals to
stand up and take hands with
conservatives they disagree with and say
no you know what in a fundamentally
republican
small r republican or democratic small
the a fundamentally
free country ruled by the people through
their ballot box
this cannot be allowed to stand this
should be a point of unity
no american should stand for rioting
looting no american should stand for
laser pointers being pointed at federal
law enforcement agents who are
protecting federal courthouses
no one should be standing for this but
instead you have disgusting
ridiculous people like jerry nadler
saying that antifa is a myth what's
happening in portland to myth poof it
doesn't exist
here is jerry nadler being asked about
violence in portland by uh by flekus and
saying it doesn't exist it's all a
figment of your imagination
that's happening in portland right now
that's a myth
that's being spread only in washington
dc about antifa in portland
yes sir there's there's videos
everywhere online there's fires and
riots they're
throwing fireworks at uh federal
officers dhs is there
look online it gets crazy mr nadler
unbelievable i mean unbelievable
you can see the footage everywhere but
this is why you can't trust the media
because only now are the media starting
to report on the violence and even when
they do is through the prism of
what if trump would just go away and
remove the feds then everything would be
all better which by the way is the same
exact line as if you remove all cops
crime goes down
if you remove all cops the racial
situation in america is alleviated and
racial inequality
is is somehow vitiated in the same line
with the same predictably stupid and
horrible
effects the fact that there are so many
liberals who are willing to go along
with this shows that they're not
actually liberals they actually are on
the left at a certain point
compliance with the left becomes
membership in it when i have made the
distinction on this show consistently
for
years between the left and liberals i've
said liberals are people who agree with
me on fundamental american rights they
just disagree on the role of government
in preserving those rights
the left disagrees on a fundamental
level with american rights this is what
i talk about and how to destroy america
in three easy steps
once liberals start caving to the left
and make common cause with people who
want to destroy those rights and are out
rioting and looting in the streets
and blaming law enforcement for trying
to stop all of that they're no longer
liberals they've now converted over to
the left and they should be treated as
such
meaning they should not be treated with
this sort of open-minded tolerance
of for for open discussion that the
right treats
liberals with doesn't mean they're never
right to speak freely everybody has a
right to speak freely
but let's stop pretending that this is
inside the overton window once you're
firing fireworks at police officers
you're not inside the overton window
anymore and once you are greenlighting
that and blaming the officers and
blaming federal law enforcement
for defending courthouses you ain't
inside the overton window you're not
there's no rational discussion that can
be had with people who are literally
promoting riots and looting that cannot
be
that's not a discussion that ought to be
that ought to be
engaged in everybody's got a right to
speak everybody's got a right to burn
the flag if they want to
that does not mean that the conversation
is worthwhile or useful
the overton window needs to be needs to
be maintained
by liberals and conservatives and it
needs to be a lot broader
than it has been with the direction
toward mainstream conservatism and a lot
less broad to include people who are
doing acts of actual violence
okay meanwhile speaking of the overton
window broadening in weird directions
got to talk for just a couple of minutes
about this insane promo that was put out
by netflix so it's always good to know
that the companies that you spend your
money on are using that money in order
to promote
insane social leftist policies so
netflix is now pushing open trans
propaganda
i mean absolute propaganda not just the
sort of normal stuff that you see
in in on mainstream television channels
with the assumption that men can become
women and women can become men but now
they are lecturing medical professionals
the medical professionals are supposed
to treat biological boys as biological
girls
so yesterday netflix put out a tweet the
tweet was
i guess this is from a show i i it's
called
here's what they here's what they
tweeted out i guess there was some sort
of documentary that they did
on a transgender young person named
bailey who's a biological boy that
they're treating as
a girl when bailey comes down with a
fever marianne rushes her to the
hospital where two doctors misgender her
marianne firmly corrects them
misgendering is traumatic this is one of
the baseline ways cisgender people can
show up for trans people in their life
hey here is the insane clip from this
netflix documentary
i know that you guys are busy but
as you would see if you looked at her
and not her chart
bailey is not a boy and by treating her
like one you are completely ignoring who
she is
you're making her feel insignificant and
humiliated
and that's not going to help her feel
good or safe or calm
so i'm here on now please recognize her
for who she is
and if at all possible could you find me
a non-blue hospital gown
i apologize okay this is insane it's
from the babysitter's club this is a
show for kids
right isn't this this from the
babysitter's club correct yep this is
from a babysitter's club a show directed
at 10 11 12 year old girls
yeah that you have some young girl
lecturing a doctor
on how to uh on misgendering people okay
well here's the thing
they better hope bailey was in the
hospital for a fever here they better
damn well hope that baby ain't in the
that bailey ain't in the hospital for
testicular torsion
they better hope baby because bailey's
in the hospital for testicular torsion
and the doctors are supposed to treat
bailly as a girl it's gonna be kind of
awkward
this is so stupid by the way we've had
cases in the united states where people
have literally died because it's kind of
nonsense there's a case i believe in
michigan
where a transgender male came into the
hospital
put on the forms i am a male reported
abdominal pain
and it turns out that the abdominal pain
was because the transgender male was
actually a female a biological female
and was pregnant but was very overweight
and because this person had written male
on their forms the doctors before
examining this person didn't treat it as
a medical emergency for the baby
and the baby died okay because of this
sort of nonsense
doctors are not in the business of your
feelings doesn't mean bedside manner
doctors are not in the business of
treating your feelings as medically
as medically relevant to diagnosis of
fever
okay that is not the way the doctors
operate this is nuts
and they're putting and they're stacking
this into shows for kids into shows for
small children
and this is a show for for nine ten
eleven-year-old people
and you're being told that little boys
can become little girls and then if a
doctor comes in and treats
the boy as a boy the doctor has done
something wrong
boys and girls have different biology
gang i'm sorry to inform you that
biology matters
but biology damn well matters it matters
in definition of sex it matters in
definition of gender and guess what
it matters the most in medical contexts
this is nuts
think of bailey a vaginal exam i mean
bailey is a boy
this is it you this is totally it's
totally crazy obviously
but this is where conservatives need to
understand
the culture is being lost on this level
and conservatives like to fight back on
the governmental the culture is being
lost on this level
because conservatives refuse to fight
back on the cultural level it makes for
awkward conversations
it means that people are afraid to speak
out publicly but guess what if everybody
doesn't speak out publicly
and do so loudly and at once then people
will be cowed into silence one by one
when it comes to maintaining truth
either we all hang together or we hang
separately
because that's the way this is gonna
work the left has basically dictated
that everybody has to acquiesce to this
nonsense
and if you don't if you say anything
about it then you are you you're a cruel
nasty human being it seems crueler and
nastier to treat
a kid in this show let's say if this
were reality you're talking about how
old is this kid maybe eight
i mean there's a little there's a little
kid maybe seven eight years old you're
treating
this kid as as fully
functional in terms of making decisions
about gender that will affect
him for his entire life and you are
and you're preaching that to children to
confuse kids about their own gender i
mean it's just
it's absolute nonsense it's absolute
sure nonsense how far hollywood has
fallen
so i i wish to pay a quick tribute here
to hollywood before it fell it is
amazing how the talent level in
hollywood has declined
so dramatically i mean truly
dramatically i was watching some fred
astaire with my kids yesterday
it used to be the people in hollywood
actually knew how to do things like they
actually had skill sets
i'm not saying people in hollywood
contact a lot of people can but it used
to be that they would be able to sing
they'd be able to dance like i was
watching a tap routine but with
fred astaire and rita hayworth it's just
unbelievable i mean rita hayworth is
really well known as an actress
she's a terrific terrific dancer but you
know the the
old actors and actresses were iconic for
a reason
uh olivia devlin passed away yesterday
how iconic was olivia de havilland she
died at the age of 104
so long full life how iconic was she
in back to back years she played maid
marion
in the adventures of robin hood probably
maybe the greatest adventure film ever
made
and then she played and then she played
melanie
melanie hamilton wilkes in gone with the
win the following you heard a couple of
clips of olivia to haveland
are you not ashamed my lady marion
[Music]
yes i am bitterly
but it's a shame that i'm a norman after
seeing the things my fellow countrymen
have done to england
at first i wouldn't believe because i
was a norman i wouldn't let myself
believe that the horrors you inflicted
on the saxons went just and right
i know now why you tried so hard to kill
this outlaw whom you despised
it's because he was the one man in
england who protected the helpless
against a lot of beasts who were drunk
on you in blood
she's a terrific actor she was nominated
for a couple of different oscars
uh she she actually had five academy
award nominations and she won in 46
and in 49 really a terrific actress and
if you see her play back-to-back years
in one she's playing this very glamorous
maid mary and the other she's playing
uh what's supposed to be a very palette
part and she's a very beautiful woman
she plays it beautifully and gone with
the wind a movie you're no longer
allowed to watch that's exciting stuff
alrighty well we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content
a lot more to get to the world of sports
we'll get to we'll also
be getting to the insanity of joe biden
continuing to avoid interviews so a lot
more to get to stick around for two
additional hours of content a little bit
later on otherwise
show up here tomorrow in the meantime
pick up a copy of my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps you can
still
get a signed copy for like the next 24
hours at dailywear.com
otherwise we'll see you later i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinnerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nico geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton